the other staff what about that anymore
- it's thoroughly escrita mr. Giovanni
dodge named fireface go then I look down
at him and he's like
[Music]
gentlemen I've everybody putting women's
please 100-plus
for Miss Sophie Alexander everybody
my grandpa and I are super-close I grew
up in the USSR with my single mom we
live with my grandparents until I was
five and we've been best friends ever
since cuz he's the coolest guy in the
world
volunteered to fight in World War two
when he was 17 afterwards joined the
Merchant Marine and sailed all over the
world like 50 countries the whole time
he was at sea though he literally had a
parrot on one shoulder and a monkey on
the other so just the coolest dude
basically so we've stayed best friends
since then about four years ago when he
was 86 years old I got a call from my
mom and she's like hey you have to get
down here your grandpa is at Saint
John's Hospital it's an emergency
I'm like oh crap just so worried about
him get in the car driving over there
just thinking about all the boozing and
whorin has done like his whole life just
kind of getting afraid for his heart so
I get there and my mom and my aunt were
pacing in the hallway and I'm like
what's going on you guys is it his heart
and my aunt dead-serious is like no it's
his dick and I'm like what and she's
like I'm completely serious we have a
dick situation like what does that mean
and she said well apparently when you've
had your uncircumcised dick for 86 years
it starts to grow shut so she looked me
in my eyes and she said your grandpa's
dick has grown shut
and I said that's not at all what I
expected coming down here today and she
said well you know that's what we've got
going on and the doctor comes out and
he's like hey it's true what you've
heard we do have an emergency dick
situation we have to operate right away
we're just waiting for the translator to
get here so we can get started I'm like
okay so five minutes pass the doctor
comes back in and he's like so the
translator has gone home for the night
so which one of you wants to translate
this dick surgery into Russian to your
grandpa while it's happening and I look
to confer with my mom and my aunt and
there's no one there you guys just trail
of vapor I'm behind that trail just like
like two cartoon shaped like holes in
the wall behind where they were standing
they just jet it out of there and so I
look at the doctor and I'm like well I
guess this is my time to shine so I walk
in there and my grandpa's lying in the
cot and like oh my god you guys normally
his skin is so dark like 50 years at sea
you know and I'm looking down at his
face and he's Taylor Swift white just
like translucent so white I'm like half
expecting him to sit up and be like all
eyes matter it's just like really
suspiciously white and I'm like oh my
god the doctor he's like yeah yeah your
Grandpa's delirious because all the
uranus started to build up in his dick
and cause sepsis so the official
diagnosis is your Grandpa's got a septic
dick
so just tell him you're gonna have to
scream into his face cuz he's delirious
tell him we have to operate on his dick
right now and I'm like oh
scream into his face that's not a big
deal that's how Russian people talk
anyway so I just leaned over my beloved
did this because face and I'm like yeah
I might not fight a big scare and I look
down into his face and he's just like
huh just like trying to sort of like
focus a little bit but he's not sure
what's happening but there's no time and
the doctors like hey tell them we have
to give him seven shots in the dick to
get going and I'm just like yeah ah I
need to just put the kill it dip it be
skull and I looked down at his face and
he's starting to like hear some of the
words
but there's no time they're just
shooting him in the dick you guys there
shooting him in the dick I have no
choice I'm just calming them down I'm
just counting them down I'm like and
then I look down onto his balls you guys
and they are huge the biggest balls I've
ever seen in my whole life I'm like
literally looking down at them being
like does he stuff these with other
balls how does this happen
it looked like someone shoved two fists
through a peach just like upsetting and
then I'm like wow Sophia why are you
thinking about the size of your
grandpa's balls right now it's like not
a good time then I like wow Sophia you
think there is a good time to think
about your Grandpa's balls they're like
what you're getting distracted get your
head back in the dick game just shake it
off get back in there and the doctors
like tell him we have to cut the tip of
his dick open and sew the two flaps
apart so I'm like aah
I need the jazz bullet gracias that
firebase go he's a shepherd
yes Dora me me mater hey look down at
his face and he's like oh just like
these horrible haunted Halloween
soundtrack nones just like whoa
[Music]
like horrifying but they don't care
they're just cutting that dig open
they're cutting it open and the doctors
like hey we forgot one quick thing Tom
before we can sew the two flaps apart we
have to squeeze all the out of his
dick all the pus so I'm like okay yeah
there's got any more sheets Tommy
biobased go and then I look down at him
and he's like but they don't care
they're just squeezing the out of
his dick you guys they're just wringing
it out like a bar towel and I'm just
standing there trying not to like lose
consciousness I was like so the two
flaps apart and I literally like stumble
out of there just like a shell of a
person and like I lean against the first
available wall and I just do the slide
that you see in the movies where the
girls like in the rape shower she's just
like everything has been taken from her
I just get all the way down to the floor
cuz I don't care about anything anymore
just like biggest balls I've ever seen
and then I look up you guys said oh my
God my mom and my aunt are back and they
have lattes and my aunt is like so how
did it go and I'm like it was the worst
thing that's ever happened and she's
like well but you know the famous
Russian saying douche was not you doing
like don there's no sweating it's good
that the other skaters in his IP school
and I'm like friendship means sometimes
you have to watch your Grandpa's dick
get cut open
that is definitely not a singing and
then my aunt is like alright you caught
me it's not a saying there is no
comforting saying we're Russian remember
life is horrible and then you die Lotte
thank you guys so much
[Music]